it's wrong that when I try to go to
sleep I read the bottle I know it sounds
wrong but sometimes when I need some
sleep
I just be like in the beginning God
created hey what's going on YouTube now
I realize I'm late with this news like I
have with most of my [ __ ] but it's been
blowing up but everybody on twatter
Bookface and instagrams is asking me the
same thing is the dress black and blue
or is it white and gold now when you ask
someone like me what a color of a dress
is and you're not my girlfriend the
dress is actually a unique shade of I
don't give a [ __ ] yes I don't get listen
I have not cared for something so much
more than this dress that I could die
right now I don't even know how you not
care for something so what you died it
doesn't even make sense but that's how
much I don't give a [ __ ]
well if you didn't care the more you
make your video on you because you asked
me to [ __ ] what the [ __ ] people have
asked me in person it has actually
gotten mad at me because I don't care
about the color of the dress are you
[ __ ] kidding me you're never what the
[ __ ] you mean you don't care you're such
a [ __ ] lady listen you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you wanna wish your
time as much as you want I don't have to
care about [ __ ] that I don't want to
care about but here are a few reasons
why you should give a [ __ ] less about
this dress so you ever know what it is
LGI baby let's get it let's go number
one in case you haven't noticed the
dress is ugly as [ __ ] now mind you if it
was prettier it had a bit of sexiness to
it I might care a bit more not from a
guy's perspective we like dresses based
on how sexy it would look on a girl
right and in this case it doesn't matter
what color the dresses or who you put it
on because it's ugly as hell I know
that's not the reason why the [ __ ]
dress went viral but I think we should
point that out if anything we shouldn't
have the comments about the color of the
dress
we should award the [ __ ] who bought it
[ __ ] looks like garbage tell me why that
dress look like it was stitched together
in the daughter with two knuckles and a
big toe what the [ __ ] do I keep on doing
this [ __ ] like I'm Italian she could
about a little bit of that the fact that
somebody actually post this picture to
ask people what color it is means that
they were intending to buy it you must
be blind actually you know what you can
go ahead and ask me what
color the dresses what's the color of
the dress david ugly number two I've
never seen people so hyped about
something so insignificant people are
using a very interesting word to
describe the color of this dress in the
flesh you're brave is it white or gold
oh my god it's amazing amazing are you
[ __ ] kidding me out of everything
that happens is the dollar man that is
the word that you want to describe a
dress amazing
there were once dinosaurs on this earth
mother [ __ ]
we shot someone into outer space you can
talk to someone on a device that lists
all to the miles away and this dress is
amazing ho mugga fascinating maybe yes
I'll give you that it's fascinating as
[ __ ] but if you're saying that the
science behind this is getting you high
now I'm gonna call you out on the [ __ ]
because [ __ ] the next time I see you in
a chemistry class you better be hype
this [ __ ] this is a chemical reaction
number three people are actually getting
mad at each other for the [ __ ] I have
seen people on Facebook to decide about
colors like his Bloods and Cripps
but it's usually black or blue code it's
not that serious
are you go in ten years of friendship
over a dress and listen I'm not saying
I'm perfect I'm into relationships on
stupid [ __ ] plenty of times I might have
told a girl to [ __ ] off was because she
said huh
that mcdonnell's wasn't real food wild
allegations how you go talk [ __ ] about
my first love and act like everything's
all cooler [ __ ]
I knew McDonald's way before you ho
McDonald's is real [ __ ] just like how
much I hate your guts she told me that
in the car in the middle of the freeway
guess what I did I told her her breath
smell like donkey dick and I kicked her
ass out in the middle of the freeway
hope you're fast like [ __ ] why the type
of commas I have seen on this [ __ ] are
ridiculous and some of you girls out
there are taking the [ __ ] way too far
I'm not sure if you notice but sometimes
you girls are the meanest creatures on
earth you will take an insult
and go way too far with that [ __ ] if you
don't see why can go you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] no the dress is black and blue like
your boyfriend's ball said cuz you're
what [ __ ] ever
oh my god feel fun listen I'm not saying
that she's not fascinating but the fact
that the news actually cover this [ __ ]
blows my mind
people are dying getting shot there are
great things being found out like the
cure to cancer but the news be like
doctor mushrooms are just cure kill hold
on a second what's up what the [ __ ] is
the color of this dress the world that
we live in take your penis chop it up
and put it on the wall I just feel like
this done that people tell me I have to
care about something just because it
blew up on the internet that there's
something wrong with me or that I'm
being negative because I don't care
about something you care about listen if
the color of a dress is the most
interesting thing you've talked about in
the past year you're the [ __ ] loser
look Anna love's a little mean but in
conclusion what I'm trying to say is the
dress is like your boo [ __ ] Oh what is
going on you do now I know a lot of you
guys out there have been asking about
what happened to go for broke apparel go
for broke apparel is still around but we
are under a revamp we're gonna be better
as [ __ ] being better clothing new [ __ ]
great [ __ ] you just got to give us a
little bit more patience because we're
taking that [ __ ] that you guys helped us
out with on in the first place and we're
gonna step it up like a [ __ ] so
stay tuned for go-for-broke apparel [ __ ]
new videos this Sunday and of course on
Wednesday and yes I got some sketches
coming out for you guys because that's
what you've been asking for but it takes
a little time see y'all next time
[ __ ] and what the [ __ ] do I keep
on doing this like I'm [ __ ] the
talent a [ __ ] about anybody